this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare
learn to think like a lawyer for free
for two months by clicking the link in
the description
article 2 section 2 of the constitution
states that the president
shall be commander-in-chief and he shall
have power to grant reprieves and
pardons for offenses against the united
states
except in cases of impeachment so under
that language
can the president pardon himself that's
what we're going to find out today
legal eagles welcome back to lostplaner
where we explain the most important
legal concepts of the day
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
bell for more legal explanations
and don't forget to leave a comment in
the form of an objection today we're
going to figure out whether the
president
has the power to pardon himself but
first
let's talk about what a pardon is a
pardon is an
action bestowed on the president by the
constitution of the united states
that completely sets aside or commutes
the punishment for
a crime a pardon is an admission of
guilt
so accept the pardon the recipient must
essentially admit that he committed the
underlying crime
now a pardon only applies to quote
offenses against the united states
in other words federal crimes the
president has no authority to pardon
state crimes
one of the reasons that this is
particularly important now
is that president trump in a news
conference recently stated i have an
absolute right to pardon myself no i'm
not above the law
i never want anybody to be above the law
but the pardons are a very positive
thing for a president
i think you see the way i'm using them
and yes i do have an absolute right to
pardon myself
but i'll never have to do it because i
didn't do anything wrong
he also tweeted as has been stated by
numerous legal scholars
i have the absolute right to pardon
myself but why would i do that when i've
done nothing wrong in the meantime the
never-ending witch hunt led by 13 very
angry and conflicted democrats and
others continues into the midterms so
the question is does the president
actually have the power to pardon
himself
well as with most things in
constitutional law we should start with
the text of the constitution
here the text of the constitution
provides a clear limit on the
president's pardon power
the pardon clause provides that the
president cannot pardon anyone in cases
of
impeachment now there is an open
question as to whether a sitting
president can be indicted
or whether the only remedy when a
president has committed some sort of
wrongdoing is
impeachment in fact i did a whole video
on that there will be a link to that
down in the description
if impeachment however is the only
remedy when the president has committed
a crime
then it would make sense that the
impeachment exception to the pardon
power would prevent the president
from pardoning himself and if the
president cannot pardon himself because
that necessarily
implicates an impeachment inquiry this
principle could extend to individuals
whose actions may be relevant to that
same impeachment inquiry
for example paul manafort or mike flynn
or other members of president trump's
campaign and staff
have credible allegations against them
that may implicate the president and
therefore by necessity
that may implicate impeachment which
would prevent the president from issuing
any kind of pardon as regards
himself or as it regards the other
members of his cabinet
but the impeachment exception to the
president's pardon power has never been
tested
so it's an open question whether that
actually provides a limit against the
president pardoning himself or not
but on top of that there is also a
general principle in u.s law
that a person cannot be the judge in
their own case
in fact in 1974 when president nixon
asked the
office of legal counsel the olc to
determine if he could pardon himself
the olc relied on that principle in
saying that president nixon could not
pardon himself
in the famous august 5th 1974 memo
mary lawton the acting assistant
attorney general wrote quote
under the fundamental rule that no one
may be the judge in his own case
the president cannot pardon himself four
days later
nixon resigned in disgrace so given that
president nixon's staff opined that he
could not pardon himself and that even
president nixon would not go so far as
an issue of self-pardon
that is potentially persuasive authority
that the president doesn't have the
power to self-pardon
now there's really only one supreme
court case that's on point in this
particular case
and that is the ex parte garland case
from 1866.
this is a supreme court case that often
gets used as an example of how the
president's ability to pardon is
basically unfettered
but i think there's actually a different
principle that is more important here
the ex parte garland case concerned
congress's ability to exclude members of
the confederacy
from practicing federal law after the
civil war
and whether the president could pardon a
confederate senator the supreme court
held five to four
that the president could in fact pardon
the confederate senator
but more importantly the court held
unanimously that the supreme court has
the authority to
interpret the scope of the pardon power
like the bedrock supreme court case of
marbury versus madison
ex parte garland is probably less
important for the actual outcome of the
case
than the principle that the supreme
court has the overview authority
to interpret the constitution in this
case and make a decision
one way or another in other words it's
less important as to whether the
president has the pardon power in
question
than the fact that the supreme court has
the ability to review the president's
pardons in the first place
so if i was going to try to predict what
would happen if a president ever tried
to pardon himself
the way thing stands it appears that
there's nothing that would stop the
president from pardoning himself
in the first instance but under current
supreme court case law the supreme court
has the power to review that pardon
and if i had to guess what the supreme
court would do with a self-pardon
i would think that the supreme court
would actually nullify the president's
self-pardon on the grounds that either
the president cannot be the judge in his
own case
or that the impeachment exception
applies which prevents the president's
pardon from going into effect
now regardless of whether the president
actually has the power to self-pardon
it is almost universally acknowledged
that if a president ever did try to
pardon
him or herself that it would almost
certainly lead to impeachment by the
house and senate and removal from office
but that is not necessarily required by
the constitution
but frankly i think i speak for a lot of
people when i say that i hope
we never have to actually test that
legal principle in action
just to be on the safe side members of
the current administration might want to
brush up on their job skills just in
case
like for example learning a new language
like russian
i'd recommend alina sichova's skillshare
course on basic russian
i hear there are many job opportunities
for senior campaign officials in russia
and it always helps to learn the
language of your employer skillshare is
an
online learning community that has over
20 000 classes on everything
like lifestyle design and technology the
first
500 legal eagles will get two free
months of skillshare when you click on
the link below
the free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics so
you can improve your skills
and learn new things now premiere [ __ ]
valuchi roosky yazig
so click on the link get two free months
and start learning today
and until next time i'll see you in
court